CAP accreditation
only fools rush in.
But you are different
because you are watching
this video.
Hi, I'm Anthony.
Cap accreditation,
the highly acclaimed
certificate in the lab
that will CAPtivate
any future partnerships for.
For your lab.
The reason why you get it
is because it shows
you're legit.
It shows
you are the CAPtain
of the lab.
Who knows how to run it
effectively
with clear documents
on everything about
your lab
and actually
following through.
So that's why we're
going to go over an overview
of how to get CAP accredited
in your lab.
So let's get started.
CAP stands for the College
of American Pathologists.
What they basically do
is it's an organization
to help ensure that
your lab maintains
the highest standards
for accurate test results
and improving patient
care and safety.
The other reason
why it's important
is because this opens up
so many doors for lots
of opportunities
and partnerships
with other companies
that need testing,
whether it's
for testing results
or researching new drugs.
And that's just a service.
If you want
to apply for CAP,
the very first step
is to go to the website
and apply cap.org.
Shocking. I know.
And once you do that,
they should send you
a welcome kit with
links to resources
as well as an onboarding
call
with a cap representative
who will guide you
through the process
just to give you a heads up.
There's a deadline of around
three months
to complete the application,
so you want to make sure
that you actually finish it
within that time period.
Otherwise
you might have to reapply.
The second step is
that you will receive
a multiple
customized checklist
for your lab based on
the type of testing
your lab does in order
to receive
CAP accreditation.
For example,
if you only
do COVID testing,
you may have to tackle like
four checklists, ensure
that it meets
the requirements.
Now, if you do something
like cannabis
and COVID testing,
then you probably have
many more checklists.
And this will be really hard
to describe for you
specifically and your lab
because, well,
it's customized.
So this means that you
have various departments
and perform different
types of testing.
Then you won't have
the same exact process
as another lab.
But what we can show
you is learning
what one lab did
that we know of that
got cap accreditation.
And this can help you
because you can have
like a rough idea
of what
to expect for your lab.
So once you receive
the customized checklist,
then you will want to
schedule an inspection date
which is then mailed
and or emailed to your lab.
The inspection,
it usually takes
around six months
and this is where
the real grind begins,
prepping for the
onsite inspection.
The good all fun, fun time.
So let's get started
with one of
the most important things
to check is making sure
that you have the IQ
OQ documentation
for all of your equipment.
What IQ/OQ stands
for is installation
qualification and
operation qualification.
And what this means
is that
your instruments
are installed and
functioning properly.
The next thing
you want to have
is full documentation
on your validation.
And what
that basically means
is that your tests
that you run
are reproducible
and accurate
for all samples.
And this is really important
because you want to have
a standardized way
to actually get results
no matter
who is operating equipment.
And finally,
you need standard
operating procedures,
also known as SOP's
and documents
for everything.
And I mean everything,
everything.
First thing we're
going to cover is SOPs.
Separate your SOPs
into three categories
pre analytical, analytical
and post analytical
pre analytical SOPs
are anything that's done
before you start
analyzing the sample.
So this can include things
like how did you specimen
collection ascensioning it
and listing out
the specimen types
and requirements.
So basically what you do
with your sample
before you start
actually testing it.
Analytical SOPS
are where you document
the actual testing process.
So this means writing out
exactly what you use
and do from the beginning
to the end,
which can include things
like manipulating
the samples,
using any automation
instruments, or even how
the sample
is being transported
within the workplace.
I feel pretty good.
Finally, the last type
is post analy-
Okay, can you scroll back up.
A jinxed myself, DERP.
Finally.
The last type is
post analytical SOPs.
And as the name suggests,
this means documentation.
Anything post analytically.
This includes things
like what you do
afer the reporting result is
out, such
as how to contact
your clients, how
to notify providers
and correcting any reports.
Now,
another component
of SOPs
you will need to do
is cover safety.
And safety is huge
in the lab because,
you know,
they want you to
be safe in the lab.
And what basically every lab
needs is a safety binder,
which includes safety
instructions and an SDS
SDS stands for
safety data sheet.
And basically
you can think of it
like a cheat sheet with
chemicals and properties
and how to handle them if
something ever goes
wrong buffer in your eyes,
and there
will be instructions
on how to rinse it
out immediately.
Or someone started
drinking some chemicals
because they thought
it was water
and then they found out
it was actually 100%
pure water
meant only for testing.
Then it probably would
have instructions
to send them
to a hospital or something.
And that's the
point of the SDS..
Then there's also a list
of requirements
for the small things
that you really don't
think about, but at the time
actually comes out.
It's there,
like have an eyewash
within a certain
amount of feet, having exit
signs on the doors
easily visible.
It's those small things
were it's very important
and I bet you're going
to start noticing the exit
signs in the lab now.
And plus, this can
also include things
like having a safety shower,
hand-washing stations,
first aid kits,
fire extinguishers
and making
sure that everything
is marked and easily viewed.
And we mean that
you want everything labeled
such as certain
cleaning bottles,
for your workstation
and equipment.
So it's very clear
that you're cleaning
with certain chemicals.
You also have to be
even specific on
when those are changed out
and scheduling it
whenever it's changed.
Yes, it's even the granular
things like this
where stuff.
Drop means go back up.
Yes, it's even
the granular things
like this stuff that CAP
standards look out for.
And then there are things
like keeping
a maintenance binder, making
sure the lab is clean,
tracking the inventory
the lab supplies,
tracking the temperature
and humidity, tracking
the cold
storage temperatures, doing
all the safety courses
for lab hygiene,
doing all the training
and competencies
for every process.
And that's
just the main overview.
I did warn you it would be
a lot of SOPs.
That's typically
why CAP accreditation
typically
takes around two years
because you have
to get all of this
documented, all of it,
and then they have
to implement it and ensure
that it's followed.
Otherwise there isn't
much point
to the documentation
we know that Media Lab has
something called
an inspection proof
where you can upload
the checklist
that CAP provides,
which is super helpful
because it helps
to keep track of the
nitty gritty stuff.
Plus, the reason why people
like having an online system
is because you can have
all the documents
organized online
and stored in one place.
It's time to stay
modern guys.
So instead of having
those tons of binders
with papers,
we highly recommend
that you check out
an online system.
Now, the next thing to cover
is a documentation
for training,
and I think you may start
to get an understanding of
what CAP is looking for,
but you want documentation
on everything.
The goal is that
you want to make sure
that all the lab
techs and anyone in the lab
performs processes
in a standardized way
and knows exactly what
to do with every scenario
and how to use each lab
equipment properly.
This means that they need
one document training
and then to a competent,
How do you say that word?
Competency assessment.
This is especially important
if you do multiple
kinds of tests.
For example, let's say
you do COVID testing
and then you also do gut
testing in your lab.
And let's say during COVID
19 that all the lab tests
were primarily
doing COVID testing.
They have a muscle memory
on the exact routine
since they've been
doing it for over a year.
But then someone
needs gut testing.
And what
we want to make sure is that
they could have
potentially forgotten
a step or two
during the gut testing
because someone needed it.
And that's the purpose
of the internal competency
to make sure
that the lab tech
can still perform a gut test
with the right
skills and knowledge.
So once you complete those
internal training documents,
you also need a place
to store
your personal documentation
for each employee.
This includes, at a minimum,
your education
degree, your resume,
a job description
and license if applicable.
Something to consider
is also having documentation
on how to navigate
your LIM system
and how to use it properly.
A LIM
system is a laboratory
information
management system
which basically helps you
to effectively manage
samples and associate
the data
in an organized way.
Basically, you can easily
track the progress
of your samples.
It can also include
things like
tracking reagents,
tracking your
inventory management,
sample management,
the process of the samples,
and even reporting
your results.
And finally,
you want to enroll
in a proficiency
testing program.
I know
CAP has a program,
but there's also
other programs like the
American
Proficiency Institute
where they send samples
with a known result.
And you just
want to make sure
that you can get
the same results
as them to verify
that your testing
is accurate.
Because if it's not done
well, that's going
to be a huge red flag
that some parts of
your testing
may not be right.
And once you
finish all of that,
then you wait
the onsite inspection day.
They'll be using
the same
customized checklist.
So there should be
no surprises and
you will receive a copy
of their report at the end.
So if
there are any deficiencies
or some things that
you may have missed
then you have 30 days
to respond
to any deficiencies,
they will then review
your application
and hopefully you'll receive
a CAP
accreditation certificate
by mail
to the lab director.
You're basically
at the finish line.
The last thing you want
to do is
you want to maintain
this CAP accreditation
after all the hard work
you did,
and you just want to
perform self-inspection
and just make sure
that you maintain compliance
so that you don't lose it.
So that's the overview,
creating documentation
for every single
thing in your lab
and following it.
If you like this video,
be sure to
like and subscribe
to this channel. peace out.